citizens of the reject Nation it's me T
Ericson alongside this guy hi yeah I'm
new here he is he's very very new so be
nice to him leave him lots of nice
comments and tell him how cool his
outfit is he already got real rejects
for even though he's a newbie anyway
we're watching Madagascar we both we
haven't seen it it's like a cartoon in
animation you guys are probably going to
be like it's not a cartoon it's
animation hush up listen leave a like
leave a comment tell us how cool we are
also don't forget to ring the bell
ring the bell oh he joined me that was
good also thanks to prepper for helping
us edit down these videos and also don't
forget if you want us to call you super
sexy I feel like this voice is more sexy
than English than what I've been doing
then join patreon cuz then you get super
sexy over there and you can sync up with
your own CT pee is a terrible accent
sing it with your own copy also Greg and
John have lots of watch alongs and
highlights on there exclusively him and
Greg exclusively on patreon so you got
to get over there get sexy get patreon
you if you know what's good for you
anything else that they should know
today John we are about to fill in a a
tremendous Gap in our childhoods finally
we will be complete people yeah it's
true I'm excited Dream works here we
go
got to say this is not the tone of music
I was expecting yeah it's very like it's
very reverent
yeah
okay whoa zebra George of the Jungle or
the
Safari is this going to be like I feel
like someone's going to start singing I
won't have known that this was also a
musical you you and me both
sister Jada pink yeah hey hey still with
will when they made
this kind a stacked cast that's exactly
what I look like when I run
surprise
dainty
oh Alex do not interrupt me when I'm Day
Dreaming when the zebra's in his own
leave him alone bars happy birthday met
thanks oh ah hey um I got I got
something stuck in my teeth stick your
head in there Dr Marty DDS is in the
house I like that he knows what degree
you need to be a
dentist just don't talk with your mouth
B right here who what the heck is this
going happy birthday a that's so sweet
check it out check it out look at that
woo look at that look at that ah a
little narcissistic you don't like it no
no it's great you hate it I should have
gotten you the Alex alarm clock that's
the one that's the big seller no no
no another Year's coming going and I'm
still doing the same old thing stand
over here over there as it was meant to
be break out of that boring routine how
throw out the old act get out there who
knows what you're going to do add lib
improvise on the Fly boom boom boom I
should follow those instructions I could
do fresh works for me funky fresh I
should start new I should start getting
out there doing improv yeah leave the
zoo teror new things it's Friday Friday
field
trip where are we going did you get your
slip signed if you don't get your slip
signed you can't go on the field trip
you could just you know yeah you can
forge it yeah Forge it want teach the
kids calling in sick what I found a
brown another brown spot on my shoulder
right here see right Mel you know it's
all in your head poor Melman he's a
hypochondriac I love calling in sick
though it's the
best my man he doesn't even have to look
down to see what's in
there don't even talk to me till I've
had my trash coffee
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love it lions are so hard to see at
the zoo they never come out they are
always chilling or sleeping which is
Advanced
chilling all right got a good crowd he
got some
moves whoa uh that's pretty cool dude
what are we are we at SeaWorld this is
great better believe
it this is the zoo for gifted
creatures whoa oh my God what is
happening to
Melman just smile and wave boys Kowalski
progress report we're only 500 ft from
the main sewer line and the bad news
we've broken our last shov
no Rico we need shovels and find more
popsicle sticks me Skipper I want you to
look cute and cuddly private I feel like
I've seen a short about these guys
that'll be here for my whole life
365 days a year please don't forget to
never spay or n to your pets oh my tip
your cab cuz it's broke damn ooh new
friends that looks like Chris hasn't
Chris Rock played a cabby me brothers
and sisters were haot to death but I
love the Chinese food here what kind n
is this Manhattan Hoover
[Music]
Dam what are you guys doing we're
digging to
Antarctica you keep a secret my
monochromatic
friend you're both well you guys got the
orange bills we don't belong here it's
just not natural this is all some kind
of whacked out conspiracy of course it
is zuanon tell me where it is
you didn't see anything of course
not the King of New York City oh he not
going to want to leave the lion no cuz
he's so famous yeah he's the star of the
show but what do you think it feels like
to be a real lion not a big star living
your life on the
plains what is this their dinner oh my
get out of town this is the life I mean
uh this is
amazing oh my God he's got Pepto in
there oo I'll live at a zoo for this
treatment yeah this is like the most
high class Zoo around in terms of animal
treatment yeah theer thanks I love it
Melman I love it yeah said that's a
mouth thermometer you know that was my
first rectal
thermometer you knew it was coming Pete
that's great kids love rectal
thermometer jokes you live in AO you
look like a
monkey two
two I
say a it's okay my guy let's make a wish
baby
cakes that has fro loops on it oo I
don't want it anymore keep my wife's
cake out your
mouth would you just tell us I mean
really what could happen I wished I
could go to the wild the wild
who who jeez told you it was bad
[Music]
luck the most fun way to choke to death
there's certainly none of this in the
wild this is a highly refined type of
food thing that you do not find in the
wild I mean not in that he doesn't know
that it's steak it's like this thing
here that I eat every day yeah doesn't
it bother you guys that you don't know
anything about life outside this Zoo
nuh-uh nope well I mean come on that's
just one
subject yell little Schmutz right
there it's well animated Schmutz it's
has been making me want cake all this
time with Froot Loops and gummy bears on
it I've never had that before come on
he's your best friend night Marty night
glow
no nice everybody has days when they
think the grass might be greener
somewhere else I'm 10 years old my life
is half over and I don't even know if
I'm black with white stripes or why
black stripes uhoh identity crisis your
my dude I'm thinking of a song please
not now oh yes it's a wonderful song I
think you're familiar with it what's it
going to
be you know you know the words two
little words New York New
York shut up oh first time in New York
hey I'll knock your tun right off pal
you and one Army stri you mess with him
you mess with me
Howard oh jeez uh there's a lot of
reptiles in there team the two of us
just go running off to the Wild by
yourself yep nope good you and me let's
go yes it's a straight shot down Fifth
Avenue to Grand Central we'll grab a
trade head north we can be back by
morning no one will ever know yes yes do
it a they forgot to turn off the
ambience again uh you know I got
it
oh much
better love that fall asleep to some
people sounds sounded like someone was
dying but I'm sure that's just that's
just New York that's just New York baby
wherever you go yeah it's part of the
experience if you haven't heard
someone's Misfortune you're not in New
York you know how I have that bladder
infection and I have to get up every two
hours well I got up to pee and I looked
over at Marty's pen which you know I
usually don't do I don't know why but I
did what's going on it's Marty he's gone
uhoh how long has he been working on
this Marty he wouldn't fit down there
Marty Marty Marty
this search to the ha bals we got to we
got to I mean we got to we got we got to
call somebody who are you going to call
Ghost
Busters get me missing animals and hurry
we've got a lost zebra probably on the
way to Connecticut by now and we're
going to
need we can't call the people that's
F wait no I wanted to read all the
stickers he's not thinking straight we
got to stop him from making the biggest
mistake of his life he's probably out
there lost and cold uhoh cut to poor
little guy
yeah so
happy damn by way are
you no time to
talk get it get
it I feel like John knows more of the
moves to this song than I do which is
not surprising me and disco you can't
stop it what's the fastest way to Grand
Central oh you should take
Lexington okay we we should take Lex and
oh my
God I love it I've done that I heard Tom
Wolf speaking at Lincoln
Center who of course we're going to
throw poo at
him I got to learn some ASL that room
has some Nifty little sinks you can wash
up in and look free Min
hey this is an urgent mission to save
Marty from throwing his life away
where's the
train ah here it comes I can't believe
Melman just ate a mint out of off off
the off the ground ground yeah that is a
urinal cake he's on your left after
Vander buil okay you hit the Chrysler
Building you gone too far uhhuh thanks a
lot
officer oh
man let's
go better tip my man oh no ow oh
hey hey just chill out it's not that big
of an emergency hey
who okay Grandma go old lady with the
brick
purse get a grip on yourselves people
you're a bad kitty a looks like I'm
going to have to take the Stanford
loope I got him he's got him
he's no w this is going to get one in on
everyone it's great how can you do this
to Marty I thought we were your friends
big deal guys we're running out don't
you ever do this again oh my
god wow holy
toale is it the cops you should be
sending there no other crime happening
in New York there are so many cops nope
this is a utopian future where only the
zoo animals are causing Ruckus
cute and cuddly boys cute and cuddly yes
oh you know what everything's cool we
just uh had a little situation here
little internal situation actually my oh
come on just want a little cuckoo in the
head hey don't be calling me cuckoo in
the head sh I dude my man's posing right
now look at this old lady just she's
just ready to throw down that's what
that's what the old lady does she just
travels the city to get some licks
before she retires for the night hey
Alex lion from the
zoo whoa well he's going to shoot you
don't do it what's the matter with them
oh in the butt of course in the butt hey
oh I love you
guys I love you so
much okay yes this is going on a trip I
expected
C oh my this is random I love it I'm
enjoying this so far yeah now they are
to be sent back to their natural habitat
where they will live their lives in the
freedom they
clearly wow
oh
interesting jeez oh no another one yes
it's the candy
man oh
oh some fun eyeball animation wait where
what I'm in a box it's Alex in a box
you're here what's going on are you okay
this doesn't look good Marty Alex Marty
is that you Gloria you're here too I am
loving the sound of your voice sleeping
just knocks me out is that are you okay
yeah no I'm fine I like this how is it
cool I like that framing device with the
quadrant it's a zoo transfer Zoo
transfer I have an appointment with Dr
Goldberg at five oh no no other Zoo
could afford my medic I am not going
HMO oh man I've just been exploring hmos
don't remind me man I'm here to escape
can't do it
now these guys are like the Scrat of
this universe it's like instead of
cutting to him in his little Walnut
Acorn thing we cut to these guys Yeah
scratch from Ice Age in case that
reference didn't didn't clock the people
loved you it's only because they didn't
know the real you make me come up there
I get the whooping on both of y'all
that's right they cancel each other
out it's no good skiper I don't know the
code oh my God don't give me
excuses and shut him
up
oh I did it turned around oh my
God where are we going oh that's a tight
okay this is going to take us this is
not going to take us to Antarctica is
Antarctica oh oh no I hope y'all know
how to
swim Mar up
[Applause]
whoa
ah how are they going to get out of this
[Music]
pickle a this is so sad kind of tragic
yeah wo wo wo
Oh Oh Land land
[Music]
who for the time this is made the
textures aren't too bad it's like his
especially with his hair I like the way
his hair moves and stuff but I feel like
for an animation it feels like very
stylistic like they chose for it to seem
very real but not too real I don't know
if that makes sense no yeah it's like
it's stylized enough and it's trying to
emulate real textures enough in the
right it's like well chosen where they
put the attention to details on that
totally out of this thing right now
hello somebody Melman I
got it's lucky they all floated this way
Alex what are you doing I'm getting out
of the
box what's out of the
box
giraffe oh my God no no why don't you
just break the other side of the Box
open cuz this is
funnier it's
Gloria it is
Gloria good thing he didn't get
probed oh
nice God Melman is taking a
beating
oh that was going to be dead by the end
of this oh my hello
mermaid oh my oh fun wow that was okay I
have so many questions about that
there's a lot going on
there yeah like this water doesn't look
too bad man he's just learned to surf on
dolphins already look at him go he's
meant to be in the
[Music]
wild requisite angelous joke for the
kids
uhoh where exactly is
here
[Laughter]
uh-oh oo
pretty San Diego yes
cleverly simulated natural environment
wide open enclosures I'm telling you
this could be the Sand Diego Zoo yep it
is definitely 100% wow that looks
real right to the camera now I'll have
to compete with Shamu and and a Smo
little grin I can't top that can't top
it I'm ruined hey I'm done I'm out of
the business competition makes you
better don't you hear that
sounds like a party
yeah oh
yeah see this is spooky Alex just in
time for post Halloween viewing
yeah oh
no that tree looks like some other
animated movie Tree Tarzan's tree or
something from Lion King I don't know
yeah this is like a puppy p
I like it it I like it it yeah like it
oh my
God I am having an acid
flashback finally context for something
children used to like obsessively reside
at me you're move it nice and sweet
and who is King Julian's voice where's
Alex what happened to him he was right
behind us what are me right behind us I
don't know where he's at but he's
missing one heck of a party
the are attacking oh no oh
no oh no no no no Alex going to help him
out yeah he
better oh my hi we just got in from New
York and we're
looking this
little I don't know how things are uh
yeah I don't know how things are
normally around here obviously there's
been oh that is a big Halloween spider
it
is get get it get
it run little spider I have a plan
really I've have devised the cunning
test to see whether these are Savage
Killers is that Sasha Baron maybe doing
a voice I know it said his name in the
credit so maybe let's just agree to
disagree my
friend hi
[Music]
there buddy big mean lion scare you he
did he's a big bad old putty Ted isn't
he come on
Mama oh my God I want to dunk him in my
coffeee they are just a bunch of pansies
uh a surprised they they called him
pansies presenting your Royal Highness
our illustrious King Julian the 13th
self-proclaimed lord of the Lemur etc
etc hooray everybody that's Cedric yeah
lord of the
[Music]
lias what is he like King of the guinea
pigs hey they're lemur man not cool what
big teeth you have shame on you Maurice
can you not see that you've insulted the
freak oh my God these guys pansy freak
yeah we got to get one more in out where
are you Giants from from New York and uh
we H the New York Giant
York which writer was like this is my
hus this is my calling card joke we both
have the people of
course well great good few they up
there
whoa so do you have any live people no I
mean if we had a lot of live people here
it wouldn't be called The Wild would it
uh-oh oh wipe yourself with a leaf type
wild who was wait where's my triple ply
I like how this world is more saturated
in color I think it's really pretty oh
good
call really good
call help what are you whoa so the
people didn't dump us here on purpose as
soon as they realize what happened
they'll come looking for
us they're already on their
way I like the Marty's in the background
like posing once the thing's done sound
mind and unsound body have divided my
estate equally among three
of no Classic this is your side of the
island and this is our side of the
Island come on no no back back back you
know what I'll be over here on the fun
side of the island this is the fun side
where we're going to have a great time
surviving until we go homeo I love this
side this side's the best you're on the
Jersey side of this cess pool oh shots
fired just look at him he's helpless
without
us what
amazing oh my God that is the fun side
yeah shut up
Spalding ah Wilson is his Nia
Wilson she is phito oh Light It Up by
any risk res boat within a million miles
to miss baby whoa that is legit that's
awesome why can't we just borrow some of
Marty's
fire that's Wildfire we're not using
Wildfire on Lady Liberty bring me a
Zippo lighter I've been doing I can't I
can't I can't do it I just I can't do
it I hope you lined her torch with
something though otherwise she's going
to burn down oh no
oh no no no bye-bye who could have seen
this coming don't worry cats always land
on there
face what kind of cat are you he's a
famous one he does not to land on his
feet oh no wicker man no you maniac the
Beast not the Beast we have been
attacked and eaten by the dreaded fousa
the f
Twilight Zone jokes for the kids does
anyone wonder why theusa were so scared
of Mr Alex uh-oh maybe we should be
scared too what if Mr Alex is even worse
than the fosa oh that dude just gives me
the HEI mace you did not raise your hand
Therefore your heinous comment will be
stricken from the
record a wowe nice I like his
articulating hand
yeah we will make sure that they wake up
in
Paradise now who would like a cookie me
me me pick me me too me too I
legitimately went on to saholic last
night to order cookies and then the
price was like $22 and I was like I'm
just not gonna have cookies today dude
they didn't let you do a paying for no
five bucks a month for your
cookies melin and Gloria over there
having a good time there's room on the
fun side for one more no thanks stubborn
old lion could you just give it a chance
come on it really isn't the fun side
without you
a that's so sweet you need to go over
there with your friends help I need
somebody you're on the hell side it's
great that great as an adult I like the
adult jokes in the kids
movie you know I've been kind of a jerk
Marty but I've been thinking about what
you said and I'm sorry okay welcome to
CAD wall take a load off there's no
wall wiping his feet on the wild sweet
wild man is want to go to this bar this
is yeah this is awesome what a
bungalow this is
seawater oh you don't swallow it it's
just temporary until the Plum's
done seaweed on a stick oh sure
seaweed on a stick I love me a seaweed
snack check this
out a million staks fall from the
ceiling fasman yawn all around wow look
at
that
wow it's shooting star make a wish quick
o how about a thick juicy steak I
promise you I'm going to find you a
steak tomorrow I like that he wish for a
steak and not to go back to New York
yeah it's gross he may be changing his
ways mhm get him a fousa
steak I want to go to where the stars
are like that and the staks rain nightly
called it look raining from the sky yeah
oh no are they really
doing doing oh this is
from yeah oh my God is happening this
has a lot of other movie references in
it kids love American Beauty all right
there's a reason it won an Oscar right
those same kids all the kids be watching
it yeah they grew up and then later
voted for Zack Snider is the best
fan-made moment it's all the kids doing
27 28 29 30 30 black and only 29 white
looks like you're black with white
stripes after all dilemma solved good
night hey I mean
cool
yes yes they made it the pawn penguins
made
it love the boat sticking in the frame
they're like yeah let's head back oh
yeah we saw it you know it's it's all
right it was fine this
sucks try the try the Arctic TR the top
of the world instead of the bottom wake
up Alex you suck your thumb
a oh wao W okay while you were asleep we
simply took you to our little corner of
Heaven welcome to Madagascar
oo wow M
Asgard wowe that is gorgeous how about
once around the P let's get our blood
pumping get those lungs breathing all
this fresh who's with I love how
sentimental the music is I know all the
strings all the Lush strings I just
don't have the energy I don't think
that's your problem first of all that's
not how you run in the wild let's go man
put the rubber to the road you just have
to let out that
in that's it now let's build up some
St he's going to accidentally go to bite
his best friend I would not be surprised
he's going to bite him on the butt yeah
so he'll still
survive oh no no he's going to unlock
his animal instincts no he can't help it
he's in the
[Music]
wild Marty's going to have or Alex is
going to have a real rude awakening when
he has to Source his own food yeah
right I feel like a mile high for St on
r on the fly from the Del in the sky
bars my dude like you said
baby yeah
goodness oh my God I I want a lemur
massage yeah Alex is now our friend and
the nowhere to be SE it could be said
that my plan is working in a very good
working kind of way what shoe is going
to drop here I feel good feel like a
king again ooh uhoh there it is oh I
just can wait to be
king the king Alex the
oh oh boy who's he going to eat during
this feel like someone's going to get
eaten if he's a king then where is his
crown I've got a crown and it's here on
my head have I got it on it's cutting
off circulation my guy do the raw man do
the
raw
whoa wow I'm never heard that one before
yeah go wild
man all right
yeah he's looking a little
demented oh oh
no no
nover oh but they want to be your
friends yes the butt
bite won the movie ter I won the movie
you're biting my butt no I'm not yes you
are oh I have so many questions what the
heck is wrong with you oh he's hungry
it's because you are his dinner that's
dumb come come Maurice what is a simple
bite on the buttocks among friends it's
it's the 21st century you know your
friend here is what we call a deluxe
model hunting and eating machine and he
eats steak which is you wa maybe you can
turn him into a vegetarian he belongs
with his own kind by the power vested me
by the law of the Jungle blah blah blah
be what come on no
no little sleep Stripes oh
yeah call oh dude no this is not where I
expected this to go
uh-oh is this like a secret vegan
allegory eat eat that yeah yeah find
find a jack fruit try that out excellent
shut Maurice thank you well done Maurice
nice Maurice he's hold not shot I'm so
sorry
Marty he is looking strung out oh my God
I'm a monster I got to get out of here
oh no you just got to find the other
lions and see what they
do yeah you got to find your own kind
make peace with the food chain
owie oh yeah
ouch lovely Predator side he's a
predator he all right we're heading in
the right direction maybe he'll learn
something the
territory the colors of the rainbow the
wild man everything wants to each other
out there circle of life moves us
all a little cheeky it's so cute
somebody's going to eat it oh it's so
cute no no it was so cute though that is
a bit striking to the wild yes the do I
never knew I needed Terra Tera and
Satchmo let's
go oh oh my dude he he quarantined
himself this is like weirdly existential
and Grim now yeah it's they're getting
like a harsh checkin with reality what
what what are we going to do we're going
to find a way to help them come on we
are New Yorkers right yes we're tough
we're gritty we're adaptable Miss with
one of us you m with all of us
here the humans can't understand them
talk do they see all this right that's
that's what I'm wondering too these
coordinated movements that are clearly
extraordinary look it's turning it's
coming back it's coming back it's got to
be the Penguins right you guys flag down
that boat I'll go get Alex the people
are coming they can help us melman's
right oh we got to flag down that
boat what oh my God that is a fast
moving yall better move out the way
yeah wow or Freight you know ship
whatever it's called someone who knows
boats comment what kind of boat this is
a big boat now this is more like it you
where are the people we killed them and
ate their liver who is that sounds like
John meany is that psychotic lion and
our monocromatic friend myty he's right
oh no uhoh he's going to get himself
killed well boys our monochromatic
friend's in danger looks like we have a
job to do Captain's Log embarking into
hostile
environment this reminds you of Toy
Story when they try to sneak out of the
the room good call I love that it looks
like a Crayola but it just says
crayon Alex come on Alex oh the both's
here we can go home oh uh-oh oh and he's
have to save him right PA to Redemption
and he'll get a steak in the process
yeah hope fousa staks are nice and
fatty the boat came back we can get out
of here stay back this is just like
looks like scars scars area of Lion King
where it's all dark in like Moody yeah
be
prepared
yeah he's just so hangry he can't help
it this is like a werewolf movie now so
sad
oh Alex I ain't leave him without you a
so sweet we are a great big part of it
you really don't want to hear me sing
this by myself
oh yeah hey Alex uh little help help me
Alex come on Alex Alex you're right
there step into it bro come on anybody
help me
oh my God if they reenact how Mufasa
died I'm going to hate it that's where
this is
headed
oh
no hey y nice job Melman of the Jungle
thiss
the
[Music]
whoa nice
sure what did they say
fza oo
fza nice MVP most valuable
[Music]
Penguins Alex he's got to carrot that's
my kill
uhoh eat
them it's showtime
Co he was faking it my man man you
almost gave me a heart attack you can't
just come up here and sneak up on me
just cuz you're L look just go with me
on this like I said it's showtime and
they cannot hear
us my
kill they're all mine Li
scary this is my territory I never ever
want to see you on my T
again
all right I think you did it nice not
bad why do I have to close my eyes yeah
they're closed titer yes sir
R oh yeah see pescatarian hey wowe oh wa
Sushi I want sushi yes me me I Love
Sushi this is better than steak I love
it I love it the kitty loves the fishy
hey all right all right pescatarian
movie
Alex Alex here here
here yes if you spit that drink all over
me John you're
cancelled should we head back to New
York I don't know Marty I mean this is
your dream I don't care where we are as
as long as we're together N I have
decided to thank you for bringing peace
to our home I'm going to give you this
love lovely Parting Gift a I can't take
your crown that's okay I've got a bigger
Crown it's got a gecko on it hey look
Shake little gecko maybe we can make a
few side stops along the way maybe Paris
W you just R my mind Spain yeah Canada
can we cheap
meds I wouldn't even mind coming back
here for a visit sometime yeah I can do
that you say that again dude they just
set up a whole franchise don't you think
we should tell them that the boats out
of gas just smile and wave
boys I like to move it it I oh my
goodness all right I assume there's more
of these cuz that feel like a setup for
number two yeah we can go anywhere wow
how many places are our friends going to
go I don't know but that was a fun movie
I didn't expect it to be as funny as it
was and it was it kept me entertained
through out like I didn't really there
was a little bit of me there I was like
am I gonna get bored and I didn't really
get I didn't I was engaged I liked it I
thought I thought the writing was good
um
and I don't know is there anything that
bugged me I'll have to think on it I
need to drink more tea you guys what's
wrong with me some sea you need some sea
water to spit all over me there's a Han
Zimmer score credit on that I wasn't
expecting but no I I agree like this was
movie at the time this came out I think
I was kind of disinterested and I was
just sort of like ah you know I feel
like a lot of the DreamWorks movies
they're they're trying to be cool and
hip and they're mostly about the
celebrity voice cast and all that stuff
and it's just going to be kind of you
know fluff for the kids and watching
this yeah this was much
more enjoyable in the cartoon kind of
way that I like um that yeah it
certainly got its obvious humor but it
didn't rely as much on that it was a zoo
animal what sorry I just saw that I had
to call it out oh yeah like I love these
things cuz to you got to know that like
so many incidental characters are
probably just like yeah like a celebrity
stopping in for the day cuz they're
friends with somebody or else it's like
the director or the writer or something
like that um but yeah yeah like I was
from the outside uh initially kind of
cynical about this but yeah I thought
this was Charming I thought the voice
cast was solid and for what the story
was I actually thought that they did put
some effort at least into the conflicts
that arose and and you know the whole
thing about you know them struggling
with the idea of leaving the zoo life
and then finding themselves in the wild
having trouble acclimating and then the
whole thing with Alex and this
existential crisis of instinct and and
you know the the circle of life the food
chain all that stuff uh yeah this this
went to places I wasn't expecting yeah
and part of me I was watching this going
like man there I could imagine a whole
bunch of different slightly different
and much more Twisted iterations of what
this could have been yeah um but yeah
this was like a lot less like generic
and annoying than I might have expected
initially right like this is actually I
found this quite Charming overall and uh
and like the Penguins even though
they're not a huge part of it I'm like I
can see why these characters you know
took on a certain life beyond the movie
uh you know as the sort of Ice Age rat
sort of like cut to sketch every now and
again uh yeah and and the animation too
like for the time and and uh I forget
what year this was but like you know
it's certainly been a while since this
dropped and you know sometimes you go
back to an older animation and you can I
don't know you're just sort of aware
you're just like oh yeah this you watch
the first Toy Story and you're like oh
yeah this was a much earlier moment for
animations very early on whereas this I
was like yeah we've come a long way but
like a lot of the the sand textures and
the water simulations and stuff like
that were pretty good and and even the
animals like even though they're not
super photo real like you know the Furs
and and the movements and the physics
and everything like they were pretty
they were well placed and chosen
throughout this I thought yeah I agree I
feel like when we got to the island and
we got towards the end when they when he
is actually having an existential crisis
and it gets a little dark that was more
of my favorite part the beginning was
still fun but
yeah it still was I was kind of like
haha sure I'm not like wow I'm in love
with this movie but once we got to the
island uh it took off a little more for
me there which was great um and in
playing with those the the the crisis of
uh and their their friendship and then
living in the wild I also liked how they
played with the the music which set up a
little more of the joke of like them
being in the wild especially when it
made the comment of it being sentimental
I feel like they had to utilize uh which
they did they utilize uh the music a lot
to play into the jokes that were already
written there um yeah I mean I I enjoyed
it um I'm trying to think if I had a
favorite moment but I think like my
rating of it would be like a six and a
half that's a little low right so maybe
I would go seven feeling in the seven
Sev range I feel like I feel seven is is
goodz I liked everyone in it like the
performers are great um yeah Good
Chemistry Between all of them yeah I I
um I like that part but um yeah I don't
know I wasn't like oh this is hilarious
but because there's still it's a kids
movie still right I'm like it would have
been with all of the jokes they were
making that would go way over or the
references that would go way over kids
heads that I always think like what if
they made this movie and they just like
dug into we're just going to make this
for a ads and not worry about like the
um the kid aspect of it I wonder how
that would turn out I'm sure there's a
movie that's been like that right an
animated movie that's like purely made
for adult and is probably not PG-13 oh
yeah it's called sausage party and uh
Seth Rogan I haven't seen and now I need
to see that I don't know if I've seen
all of it I've seen clips from it but I
don't know if I've seen sausage party
either but no I might not want to see it
I don't know very much like oh hey all
these Food Part partly it's like they
discover what happens at least from the
trailer I remember like what happens
when you go home it's not this Utopia
it's like you know the horror of being
eaten and also and also a lot of like
food-based love making jokes oh from
what I gather I think it's like an
R-rated movie like I don't think I want
that part but
um you never know you never know you
never know until you watch an
anthropomorphized hot dog and an
anthropomorphized hot dog bun flirt
maybe it's the only thing I've been
waiting for that I didn't know I was
waiting don't change the whole way you
interact with food yeah man I mean this
made me want sushi it made me want a
tiki drink um I had I had a jolly time
it made me want to uh trip on
tranquilizers I like yeah he wants to go
back to asking for acid on the sidewalk
so you can see the candy man yeah I hey
I mean I will always uh you know have a
soft spot for an animation that does a
weird trippy drug sequence yeah that and
it was so Random which I enjoyed that
like as you said and you brought it up
as we were watching it that there are a
lot of jokes and references and things
that are done in here that kids that are
not really meant for kids it's like well
their parents have to bring them to this
film so we might as well adhere to both
we got give them something so that they
don't completely tune out and hate this
experience and not bring their kids to
the inevitable sequel yeah yeah yeah I
feel like uh I was trying to think like
why does Pixar do that so well cuz Pixar
is like my favorite I mean there are
some a lot of Dream works that does it
too but I I
feel sh tail yeah um this was probably
better than shark tail I'm going to go
out on a limb and say that this was
probably better I would agree with you
um wholeheartedly and also I feel like
uh what some other animated movies do is
that they bring in heart more into the
story which keeps it like grounded and
keeps me more engaged versus this was
just sort of like he wants to go and be
in the wild but it was a lot of it
seemed a little more on the surface and
like jokes and I get it it's made for
kids it's just for some reason it um the
the heart of it of them being extra
bonded didn't pull at me as much I mean
towards the end sure their relationship
between Alex and what's his name zebra
in the line there we go um is great I
loved it it's just the the setup I guess
with all of them maybe I just uh what I
think maybe would have pulled me in more
as a foundation between maybe all of the
friends before we got to being like oh
we're going to go off in the wild I
don't know I don't know I I know that um
other movies have pulled me in more with
just being animated and I think it just
has to do with more heart there was
still heart in this movie for sure
between um the two friends I just don't
know why I feel like it could have gone
further that's my only know I'm like oh
could it have gone further to where I
was I would be like this is an eight and
a half out of 10 yeah I don't know yeah
yeah I mean it's like you get to know
their day-to-day life you know you get a
bit of that setup but you don't yeah
it's like Melman and oh Pearl what's her
name uh Hipp the hippo yeah J uh you
know yeah they they are much more like
oh yeah they're part of the friends on S
here but uh but yeah it's clearly like
Alex and Marty are the ones that we're
going to actually get character
development on uh Beyond like what their
joke or function is right um and so yeah
yeah yeah it's like this isn't a tear
jerky one like it has sentimental
moments but yeah you're not going to go
to that Pixar place of emotionality and
and that's one thing I do appreciate
about a Dream works to some extent and
and you've been through the Despicable
Me movies and stuff is that it's like I
love a Pixar and Pixar certainly has own
slapstick aesthetic but I do appreciate
the tradition of like Looney Tunes uh
and I feel like DreamWorks animated
movies like this uh you know like how to
turn your dragon is a bit more Pixar
esque um so good yeah and and and that
that's a great Trilogy um but yeah this
is one that that feels kind of more like
a Despicable Me where it's like there's
there's some heart here but it's more uh
yeah in the tradition of Broad and
slapstick cartooner um which which yeah
I appreciate which can get annoying in
the wrong you know measures but I didn't
think this really fell into any of those
traps much at all yeah it wasn't as as
annoying as I guess you would have
expected and I think you hit the nail on
the head in regards to uh well I just
want to say that even the first
Despicable Me did have it had so much
heart in that that the first one where I
I watched them uh here I think well with
you right did I watch with Greg I watch
him with Greg God I get you guys who is
he and who is I don't know they need to
come in and Ines it was me one of them
anyway my point is IND Despicable Me the
first one had a lot of hardw I like
cried at the end with the little girl
it's there's so much there and I think
basically what we're saying is that the
slapstick stuff doesn't really work for
me I guess and the other stuff when it
has a little bit more of a heart string
pull you'll you'll sell me on it so but
I think that there does need to be there
is an audience for stuff that like
they're like we don't need to make
people cry or feel all of that much just
like make them laugh and have fun except
for me I have more fun when it's like
the heart isn't there so that's it
that's all for me I thought I would get
annoyed by the I like to move it move it
dance break uh but it was shortlived uh
so you know KN put the whole thing over
the credits that's fine that's good that
was the only moment where I was like oh
here we go we got one of these how long
is it going to last yeah I I liked I
thought the the main core voice cast was
nice and they managed to it's like you
know Chris Rock obviously especially is
bringing his personality his flavor his
you know vernacular to the role but not
in a way I feel like sometimes these
movies can fall into a pit of like being
overly referential and like trying to be
hip uh and this had the right amount of
like yeah this clearly is going to
appeal to like the modern time it's not
you know being so reverent as to have
him be like what would a zebra actually
talk like you know and uh and so yeah I
felt like it felt like this attempt is
like I've seen the DreamWorks fall into
the wrong side of that where it's like
ah some of this is just like again
annoying and it's like you're trying to
be cool but it's like annoying whereas
yeah this this had like the the right
amount of that so yeah I agree I feel
like Despicable three I watched all of
them here I think that was the one where
I was like this is kind of annoying
we've seen this over and over but all
the rest I mean I still love all of
those movies but um yes I I agree with
that um do I have any last thoughts I
don't think so I think
um yeah what I said earlier is that I
want sushi champ I want sushi we need
Sushi and champagne yeah I love to go on
a yacht this made me want to go on a
boat again you just got to wear the the
patch the the what you call it the
motion patch yeah and your nautical
themed pasme Afghan yeah and then I'm
good to go you guys so I mean you got
any last thoughts no just uh you know
this was this was fun enough that I
would watch another if if this happens
to do well and it pleases All of You Out
There Our Benevolent overlords uh then
yeah I would gladly watch another i'
watch other so you guys leave a comment
let us know what you think about this
movie should we watch more what else
should we watch we love you so much
leave a like do the Bell thing and we
will see you guys on the next one bye
[Music]
bye